-Welcome, welcome, welcome,
welcome to "The Tonight Show"!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on.
Look how festive it looks.
Guys, let's get
to the news and jokes.
Well, guys, this is exciting
and historic day,
because the United Kingdom
started giving out
the first doses of Pfizer's
COVID vaccine.
Watch this.
-At 6:31 this morning,
Margaret Keenan,
who turns 91 next week,
became the first person
ever given a tested
and vetted COVID vaccine
outside of trials.
-That's right, 90-year-old
Margaret Keenan
is the first patient
in the world
to receive the Pfizer vaccine.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Or as the Queen put it,
"Sure, sure, she was."
[ Laughter ]
"Yes, we definitely gave it
to Margaret Keenan first."
The U.K. vaccine underwent
rigorous testing.
Apparently Gordon Ramsay
would try every version
and then berate the scientist.
"You donkey, it's not a vaccine!
It's raw!"
[ Laughter ]
"It's meant to be
kept in the freezer, donkey!"
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, the vaccine
is starting in the U.K.
and then coming here.
But your one annoying friend
will be like,
"I actually liked the original
British version better."
[ Laughter ]
"Just nuanced
and way more subtle."
[ Laughter ]
That's right, it's a big day
over in the U.K.
People are calling it "V-Day"
for Vaccination Day.
Yeah, V-Day, not to be
confused with tonight's
"Bachelorette" episode "VD Day."
That's a different --
[ Laughter ]
Different thing.
Meanwhile, this is going viral.
It turns out --
this is real -- the second
person to get the vaccine
was an 81-year-old man
named William Shakespeare.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, William Shakespeare
got a vaccine on V-Day.
Which explains why he said,
"To V or not to V,
that is the injection."
[ Laughter ]
"'Tis nobler to take Moderna."
I'm glad Shakespeare got
the vaccine because in 81 years
he hasn't been able to get
a dinner reservation.
"Yes, the name's
William Shakespeare.
Hello?"
[ Laughter ]
"They hung up."
-[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
-That one got you, man?
-Yeah.
-That's funny.
[ Laughter ]
Imagine living in the U.K.
and being named
after their greatest writer,
William Shakespeare.
That's like living in the U.S.
and being named after
whoever writes
the Geico commercials.
[ Laughter ]
They're geniuses.
I don't know what's
in the vaccine,
but it must be pretty amazing,
'cause after Shakespeare got it,
he challenged Logan Paul
to a boxing match.
[ Laughter ]
Well, as the U.K.
starts vaccinating,
some news just broke out
about our own supply.
It turns out this summer the
Trump administration turned down
Pfizer when they asked
if we wanted to buy more doses.
Trump knows he messed up.
When asked about it,
he was like,
"I'm only answering questions
about Mario Lopez
playing Colonel Sanders."
[ Laughter ]
Speaking of the White House,
I read that Trump
wants to hand out mass pardons
to "every person
who ever talked to him,
even people who
don't need pardons."
Yep, Trump's handing out
mass pardons.
The only other time you hear
that phrase
is after Rudy Giuliani
eats Taco Bell.
"Pardon -- Pardon me."
[ Laughter ]
"Oop, pardon.
Pardon me, sorry.
Oh, that's a half pardon,
sorry."
[ Laughter ]
Oh, and of course,
President Trump
is still refusing to accept
the results of the election,
but he's not the only one.
A new "Washington Post"
survey says
89% of all Republicans
serving in Congress
won't accept Biden's victory.
Here's what a few Republicans
said
when asked about the election.
First up,
Congressman Greg Pence said,
"If Biden wins, I'll quit,
and focus on my Etsy product,
Lipstick for Men."
[ Laughter ]
Up next,
Senator Tom Cotton said,
"Trump will be president
by the time that gumball
I swallowed last year finally
works its way down my throat."
[ Laughter ]
Next up, Congressman
Dusty Johnson
was like,
"Don't bother me.
I'm busy losing a chess match
to that girl
from 'Queen's Gambit.'"
[ Laughter ]
Up next, Congressman
Fred Upton said,
"I trust the results,
but not the congressmen
who told me 'everyone'
was doing this pose."
[ Laughter ]
Then, Senator Mike Braun
was like,
"This election was rigged
or I wasn't once an extra
in a 'Sopranos'
restaurant scene."
[ Laughter ]
And finally,
Senator John Boozman said,
"If you have proof the election
was rigged, I'm all ears."
[ Groaning, laughter, applause ]
Very interesting stuff.
Here's a big tech story.
Today, Apple unveiled a pair
of noise-canceling headphones
called the AirPods Max.
And get this -- they cost $549.
Check them out. Yep.
Noise-canceling headphones
for $549.
When they heard,
people quarantining with kids
were like,
"I'll give you $800."
[ Laughter ]
Here are the headphones
in their case.
Yeah, great. It looks like
a stormtrooper's purse.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, listen to this.
I saw that Pizza Hut is
selling something new
for the holidays.
Check this out.
It's the new triple-decker box
from Pizza Hut.
Look at this thing.
In America, that's actually
our food pyramid.
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
In the U.K.,
they have a COVID vaccine.
In America, we came up with
the triple-decker pizza box.
[ Laughter ]
It's a great idea.
My biggest complaint
about ordering pizza
was always not having
enough cardboard
to awkwardly fold and smoosh
down in my garbage can.
[ Laughter ]
I'm turning into
Andy Rooney now.
[ Laughter ]
"That's the part I need
more of when I get a pizza.
Having to fold the cardboard
and put it in my garbage can."
[ Laughter ]
I can almost picture idiot guys
across the country going,
"Honey, you could use this
as a jewelry box."
[ Laughter ]
"Just saying."
I saw that after 70 years,
IKEA is ending
its popular catalog.
[ Crowd awws ]
I know.
At its peak,
IKEA printed up to 200 million
copies in one year,
making it one of the most
popular books in the world.
So we put together
this little tribute
to our favorite products
in the catalog over the years.
Enjoy.
♪♪
[ Dial-up modem ringing ]
[ Applause ]
Here's a wild story.
Two cousins here
in New York City ages 7 and 12,
took one of their parents'
Range Rovers for a joy ride
and ended up at a rest stop
near Delaware.
The 12-year-old was like,
"Don't blame me.
He was the one driving."
[ Laughter ]
It got worse when the kids
passed the officer
a Chuck E. Cheese token
and said,
"What do you say
we make this thing go away?"
[ Laughter ]
And finally,
I heard about a man in Italy
who walked 280 miles
after a fight with his wife,
then got fined
for violating lockdown rules.
[ Laughter ]
I'm no marriage counselor,
but it's probably
not a great sign
when someone storms out
and walks to Switzerland.
[ Laughter ]
That's last time
he gets his wife
a triple-decker pizza box
for their anniversary.
[ Laughter ]
Guys, we have
exactly nine shows left
before we go on Christmas break,
which means it's time
for that beloved
"Tonight Show" tradition.
It's time for "12 Days
of Christmas Sweaters."
♪ -12 days of Christmas
sweaters, 9 days left ♪
-That's right.
Every show between now
and Christmas,
we'll be giving
one lucky audience member
a stunning Christmas sweater
from the "Countdown to
Christmas Cabinet."
So, since there are nine
shows left,
let's open door number nine.
[ Drumroll ]
It's right there.
Very exciting. Yes.
Whenever you're ready. Yes.
Yes! Someone said -- Whoa!
That's a lot of --
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's a lot of stuff.
Oh, good -- good gosh almighty.
[ Laughter ]
That's a lot of sweater
that was in there.
Oh, my goodness gracious.
Is there something on the back?
Oh, my gosh!
Well, there's a little man
hidden on there.
There's a little man.
A stowaway on the back of that.
Alright, who is excited
to take home this sweater?
[ Cheers and applause ]
There we go.
Alright, if I call your number,
come on down.
Quest, can I get a drumroll,
please?
[ Drumroll ]
1-2-3!
♪♪
Ah, here he comes.
Welcome.
Oh, my goodness.
Thank you so much
for being here.
What is your name
and where are you from?
-My name is Tom Russell
from New Rochelle, New York.
-Hey, New Rochelle.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I know New Rochelle very well.
-There's a lot going on here.
-Well, you know, they say
during the holiday season,
"make lemonade,"
you know what I'm saying?
-Mm-hmm.
[ Laughter ]
-Would you do us
the honor of trying it on?
-Yeah, which one's the front?
[ Laughs ]
-That's up to you, buddy.
It's --
-Alright.
-It's really that much fun.
You don't know what the front
or the back is, really.
You know that it has sleeves.
That's -- The only thing we can
guarantee with our sweaters,
that there are
sometimes sleeves.
[ Laughter ]
That's a -- oh, I feel like --
oh, I feel like this
is the right way to go.
[ Laughs ]
Oh, my God!
Wow! Oh, my God.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wow, I don't even know
what to think.
I'm looking at it and I still
don't know what's happening.
-I can't see my shoes.
-It's unbelievable.
This is unbelievable.
It is a holiday miracle.
Give it up for our winner
right here.
A round of applause.
[ Applause ]
Stick around.
We'll be right back with more
"Tonight Show," everybody.
Come on back.
♪♪